We explored some of the US laws
that have been developed for
dealing with cyber crime and
theft of proprietary online information.
Now these laws could be different
across different countries.
But one thing we saw is that enforcing
them has some serious challenges.
We also discussed ethical behavior
when it comes to our online activities
that impact cyber security.
In the end, we explored online privacy.
In particular, who can collect
information about what we do online?
What can they do with such information?
Who can they share it with?
And what options do we
have in the use and
sharing of information about
our online activities?